MALE SPEAKER: Thanks for
being here everybody.
We're very lucky today to have
David Kilcullen as our guest.
And by the way,
before I forget, I
want to give a special
shout out to the men
of the 23rd marine regiment
who are here as our guests.
Thank you for your service.
David Kilcullen is a
counter insurgency expert.
He first, at least,
came to my attention
as part of the surge
in Iraq in 2007,
but his resume goes
much deeper than that.
Today, he's going to talk
about what he's doing nowadays,
which involves some work with
Google, actually, on Syria.
He's been adviser to General
David Petraeus and Condoleezza
Rice and is now operating a
consulting service in Virginia
where he deals with all sorts
of interesting stuff, which
he'll be happy to
tell you about.
So please give a warm
welcome to David Kilcullen.
DAVID KILCULLEN: Thank you.
It's actually great to be here
on such a beautiful day in San
Francisco.
I was talking to
a guy last night.
He said the problem with San
Francisco is it makes you lazy.
I was like, what do you mean?
He was like well,
yesterday I woke up,
and I had all this work
to do, but then I thought,
I think I'm just going to
go for a hike with my wife.
And I blew off the
whole-- and I'm like,
I can totally see that.
Every time I get off
the plane in California,
I'm like, why don't
we live here again?
So thank you for spending an
hour of a beautiful day inside
with me when you could be out
doing a bunch of other stuff.
Obviously, I just wrote this
book, which is why I'm here.
But I thought what I
would do is just hit up
some of the main
ideas in the book
rather than try to give
you a full download,
and then maybe in Q&A we can
kick those around, and discuss
some of the main stuff
that comes out of it,
and see what you guys are most
interested in talking about.
I began writing the book
in September of 2009
after getting ambushed
in Afghanistan.
It's not the first, or in fact,
the last time that I've been
ambushed in Afghanistan,
but this particular one
was interesting.
It was the classic late
afternoon ambush scenario
that you get in Afghanistan,
because most of Eastern
Afghanistan has a very, very
narrow set of valleys that
have settlement patterns
of-- basically people live
in the bottom of the valleys.
Nobody lives on the
mountains themselves,
and there's usually only
one road running down
the middle of each valley.
So if you go up that
valley in the morning,
essentially everyone
in that whole community
knows exactly where you're
going to be at 4 o'clock
in the afternoon.
You're going to be
driving down the valley.
And in fact, Afghan
families have ambush spots
like families in
the Chesapeake Bay
have fishing spots
or families out here.
They don't have to go through
the full complex planning
process that an
infantry small unit does
when it decides to do an ambush.
They basically say hey, Abdul.
Get to the ambush spot.
Because they have three or four
of them already picked out.
In fact, I was in another
ambush earlier in my career
in Afghanistan where we actually
found old 303 ammunition
from British rifles
that went out
of service in the 19th century
up in these firing positions
on either side of the
road, so they'd obviously
been using this ambush site
for some considerable time.
But I'm in the middle of this
ambush, and I think to myself,
this is a pretty bad ambush.
I've become a bit of an
involuntary connoisseur
over the years,
and I actually used
to teach ambushing
at the tactics school
when I was captain.
So I'm like, if these were my
students on the battle course,
I would have failed them
for their ambush plan.
It was just very
badly put together.
It didn't come-- it
just didn't work.
Anyway, we get to the
bottom of the valley,
and I'm talking to my
driver of my Amrep, which
is like a big
armored garbage truck
that we drive around
in Afghanistan.
And the driver says
to gunner, hey,
how many Taliban guys
do you reckon we killed?
And I was like, well, how do
you know they were Taliban?
And they were like, dude,
they were shooting at us.
And it took me a little while.
I was actually on the
helicopter ride back afterwards.
But I began to think maybe this
attack had actually nothing
to do with the Taliban.
And when I started to
think about what we've
been doing in that valley for
the preceding two or three
years, and the way that we
laid down a series of projects
to help the community, and how
that had actually dis-empowered
other people in the
community and created
a big imbalance of resources
going into some villages
and into others, I started to
realize that actually there's
a lot more that meets the
eye in a place like Eastern
Afghanistan around
stuff like contracting,
and around denial of
access to services,
and the way that people
interact with this giant tsunami
of contracting and aid money
that comes into Afghanistan.
About 14 times the size of the
total Afghan government budget
is our aid programming
in Afghanistan.
And I began to write
this book, trying
to think beyond the paradigm
of counter insurgency,
and for those people that
are in the military, that's
like anathema.
Like, what?
Dave Kilcullen?
Didn't you write a book
on counter insurgency?
Yes, but it's just a book,
and we have this paradigm
that we built, because it helped
us to win a conflict in Iraq,
and it helped us
to win a variety
of smaller fights
in other places.
But that doesn't
mean that it's dogma,
and that's the answer forever.
Like any other human
model or mental picture
of an environment, all it is is
a systematic oversimplification
of very complex reality.
And over time, when
you start to see
data that don't fit
with your model,
it's time to update the model.
And so what I've been doing over
the past three or four years
is thinking beyond
that and actually
reaching back into some
work that I previously
did when I was in the
Australian military looking
at urbanized
environments, and I'm
going to talk about
that a lot in a minute,
but I just want to
set the context.
Ever since 9/11, the military
in particular, but also
aid agencies,
diplomatic services,
a variety of other
organizations have
gotten really good
at the kind of stuff
that I was doing in
Eastern Afghanistan when
I got shot up in 2009.
Remote environments,
tribal communities,
landlocked countries
like Afghanistan,
the work that we do in little
remote frontier outposts
has become, I think,
dramatically better quality
than it was a decade ago.
But if you look
at the environment
that we've been operating
in, its very specific.
Afghanistan's a very
diffuse conflict.
The conflict mostly happens
in rural environments,
not in the cities.
It happens in this land
locked, mountainous arid, not
very heavily
populated environment.
And most importantly,
it's a very low bandwidth,
low conductivity environment.
Most people don't
have the ability
to tap into an extensive
cellphone network, or access
to the internet, or any
of the sorts of things
that we take for granted
in the modern urban world.
So as I was
researching the book,
I started to think
to myself, what's
going to happen
after Afghanistan?
Now, it's become fashionable
in the politics world
and the foreign
policy discussions
in Washington to act like
the war in Afghanistan
is already over, like
we don't currently
have all these troops out
there fighting and dying
on the ground, or diplomats
doing the work they're doing,
or aid agencies or
other people doing
the hard work in Afghanistan,
like that's all finished.
Actually, our friends
are still out there doing
this stuff on the
ground, and I think
it's really important
to not forget that.
That said, it's pretty
clear that the conflict
is going to start winding
down in the next year or two,
and it's worth
asking yourself what
does the future
environment look like?
Does it look like
Afghanistan, or does it
look like something else?
And a lot of the book is my
exploration of that question.
When I look at the future
environment, what I see
is a very high
degree of what you
might call operational
continuity.
The stuff that we
do, we will keep
on doing mostly
that kind of stuff
in the future environment.
As an example of that, if you
go back in US military history
to about the middle of the
19th century around the time
of the Mexican War, and
you start a timeline then,
and you run it
forward to now, you
find a really, really consistent
pattern in US military history
where we do a large scale or
long duration irregular warfare
campaign about once
every 20 to 25 years,
and we do small ones on a
scale of Kosovo, or East Timor,
or Sierra Leone about once
every 5 to 10 years in between.
And that patent is not
only very consistent
and appears to be totally
unaffected by policymakers'
preferences.
So beginning of last
year, President Obama
gave direction to
the US military
where he said we're
going to get out
of the business of doing
large scale, long duration
stabilization operations
or counter insurgencies.
He said we're not going to
structure the force for that
anymore.
Turns out President Clinton
said basically the same thing
in 1992.
Candidate George W. Bush
said the same thing in 2000.
President Johnson said
the same thing in 1964.
You can run this
back, and you'll
find about seven presidents in
the 20th century alone making
basically the same
comment, and it
has zero effect on
how often we get
into these kinds of conflicts.
Across the planet since the
end of the Napoleonic Wars,
roughly 80% of all conflict
has been intrastate--
that is within communities,
within one country-- or it's
involved a non-state armed group
like pirates, or insurgents,
or some other kind of combatant
that is not a nation state.
So that is in fact-- that's
the typical environment that we
operate or the stereotypical
type of work that we do.
But the environment that
we've operated in the past
is not the environment that
we're going to look at.
So operational continuity
but a strong environmental
discontinuity
between what's coming
and what we've been
doing in the last decade,
this landlocked remote
rural environment.
Now, American forces,
particularly the army
and the Marine Corps were
very heavily involved
in urban fighting in Iraq.
So talking to an
American audience,
it's easy to think that actually
we have a lot of experience
globally in urban operations.
That's actually not true.
There were 50 countries in
Iraq, 51 in Afghanistan,
but only one of those
that it was involved
in any significant
urban fighting
was the American
military in Baghdad.
When I deployed to
Baghdad in-- I'm
sorry-- and Ramadi and
all the other areas
around that in the
American sector.
When I deployed to Baghdad in
February of 2007, at that time,
more than 50% of total combat
action in the war in Iraq
was happening inside
Baghdad city limits,
which is a purely US theater.
Everybody else engaged
in the conflict
was out in more remote
rural environments,
where frankly there was a
lot less violence going on.
So for most of the 50
countries that we're in Iraq,
normal is not urban.
Normal is farms, little
villages, rural districts,
not a lot of fighting, more like
peacekeeping and stabilization.
And for everybody that
went to Afghanistan,
you're dealing with this
rural diffuse environment.
But looking forward,
I see four big trends
that are actually
changing the environment
and will shape how we operate or
where we operate in the future,
and those trends are population,
urbanization, littoralization--
which is just the tendency
for things to cluster
on coastlines-- and then
most importantly electronic
network connectivity.
Now, those first
three trends are old.
They've been around for at least
200 years since the beginning
of the European
Industrial Revolution.
They're also very
well understood
in the military in particular.
Let me just talk about
them briefly before I
go to what I think is
the more important one,
which is connectivity.
So, population growth, at the
beginning of the US Industrial
Revolution in 17-- sorry,
the European Industrial
Revolution in 1750, the total
population of the planet
was about 750 million people.
It took 150 years
for that population
to double through
the first century
and a half of industrialization
and the invention of things
like new ways to think
about irrigation, new ways
to think about crops,
concentration of population
in urban environments,
improvements in public health.
All those sorts of things led to
this population growth process
that began in the middle
of the 18th century.
By 1900, we were at
1.5 billion people,
so we doubled the population of
the planet in about 150 years.
We then doubled that population
again in only 60 years by 1960,
so we get to 3 billion
people on the planet in 1960.
And it's worth noting that
that second doubling happened
during the same time
frame as both world wars
and a major influenza pandemic
across the entire planet, which
between them killed
about 150 million, mainly
young and healthy people.
So despite that, we saw this
doubling by 1960 to 3 billion.
The population then doubled
again by the year 2000
to 6 billion, and in just
the dozen years since then,
we've added slightly more
than a billion people.
So today, were looking at
around about 7 billion people
on the planet.
Projecting that forward is not
a matter of simple prediction,
it's a matter of looking at
the demographic bell curve,
and where people are right now,
and where the population growth
is likely to take us.
But the Bureau of Economic
and Social Affairs at the UN
and a bunch of
other organizations
that look at the stuff
project that by the middle
of the century we're
looking at something
like 9.5 billion
people on the planet,
so about another 2.5 billion
people between now and 2050.
There is a projection
that the population's
going to top out at
around that level
and stay at essentially
9.5 billion by 2050.
That's based on
certain assumptions
about what happens to birth
rate when GDP increases,
and they may not
actually play out.
So we're looking at least
2 1/2 billion more people
on the planet in our generation.
The second factor,
though, is urbanization.
So if you go back again to the
beginning of the Industrial
Revolution and you think
about the population
of the planet at
that time, roughly 2%
of people on the
earth in 1800 lived
in a city of a million or more.
By 1900, it was 10%.
By 1960, it was 25%.
By April of 2008, it was 50%.
We're currently
sitting somewhere north
of 50% urbanization
on the planet,
so roughly half the
people on the planet
live in a city of
a million or more.
Again, the same projections
suggest that by 2050 we'll
be looking at somewhere between
65% and 75% urbanization.
So somewhere around the current
population of the planet--
7 billion people-- will
be living in a large city
by the middle of the century.
Interestingly, that
urbanization process
is not only going to account
for all the gross population
growth on the planet.
It's also going to account
for a lot of people
leaving rural
environments and moving
to the cities between now and
the middle of the century.
So actually the
urban environment
is going to grow by roughly
3 billion people between now
and the middle of the century.
Roughly 1 1/2 million people
per week migrate from a country
area to a city, so roughly the
same number of people that it
took all of human history
until 1960 to generate across
the entire planet are going to
move to cities within the next
30 years.
Edgar Peters, who's the
head of the Africa City
Center in Cape Town
in South Africa,
says we're looking at dramatic
disruptive change in just one
generation because of that
urbanization and population
growth.
That's not all, though.
Those urban
environments will not
be evenly distributed across
the surface of the earth.
They'll be almost entirely
in the developing world
in low and middle
income countries.
This is not a
phenomenon that we see
in Europe and the United States.
It's a phenomenon of sub-Saharan
Africa, that Mediterranean
basin, South Asia, Latin
America, and the Caribbean.
It's not evenly distributed.
It's developing world cities.
And those cities
are overwhelmingly
located on coastlines for
reasons of basic physics.
When you want to move
heavy large stuff around,
for all of you in
history and still now,
it's been a hell of a lot easier
to move that around by water
than on land.
So cities have tended to cluster
against large bodies of water
on rivers, on major
river deltas, lakes,
or on coastlines.
Already today, 80% of
people on the planet
live within 50 miles of the sea.
And of course, we're dealing
with what systems theorists
would call sensitivity to
initial conditions here.
So as urbanization
takes place, it's
not happening against
the background
of an evenly distributed
human population.
Cities are already
on coastlines,
so as people move
to existing cities,
they're going to be
moving to coastlines.
So we're going to see
a population that's
incredibly clustered in urban
environments in third world
cities on coastlines.
Obviously, that
changes the environment
in which we operate, but
actually the military well
understood this
stuff 25 years ago.
So a marine general
called Krulak
wrote about a thing called a
three block war in the 1990s,
and he had guys like Ralph
Peters and Robert Scales--
and these are all
military theorists
that I'm mentioning-- who really
focused on the problems of what
we call the urban littoral
back in the 1990s.
And I read some stuff on this.
It was pretty well understood
in the community at that point.
But what's happened
is the military
since 9/11 has been dragged off
into this other environment.
Now, I wouldn't call Afghanistan
a geographical fluke.
There are deserts, and
mountains, and jungles
where conflict is going
to occur in the future,
but because conflict
tends to happen where
people live and the
general parameters
of human civilization shape
the parameters within which
conflict happens, the majority
of conflict on the planet,
like the majority of
everything on the planet,
is going to happen
in third world
coastal cities by the
middle of the century.
And I can talk more
in detail in the Q&A
if you like about the
data that supports that.
But what's really interesting
to me is not these old trends.
They've been around
for a long time,
and they're well understood.
What's interesting is the new
trend, which is connectivity.
Now, I'm talking to a
bunch of people at Google,
so I probably don't need to
go into the level of detail
on this that I have with
some of the other folks
that I've spoken to, but
just a couple of data points.
In the year 2000, there were
30,000 cellphones in Nigeria.
Today, there are 113 million.
Last year, I spent some time
walking around Mogadishu
engaging with the
community there
on some work we were
doing, and Mogadishu
is a city that
survived for 20 years
without a government
or a central state.
24% of people that
live in Mogadishu
own and use a cell phone.
There are four major
cellphone companies.
Internet access from Mogadishu
is actually a lot easier
than from parts of
the United States
if you want to talk to people,
because you're very closely
geographically connected to the
international undersea cable
network.
There's a market in the middle
of Mogadishu called the Bakaara
Market, which was the
scene of a big gun battle
about 20 years ago.
On the ground floor
of that market
is a currency trading
exchange where
people are on the internet
and on their cell phones,
and they're trading the
Somali Shilling, which
is the currency again
that survived for 20 years
without a central bank.
It floats on international
exchange rates.
It gets updated
five times a day,
and the traders on that floor
punch out a SMS text message
to everybody that trades
in the city five times
a day with the
current exchange rate.
And so you have
all these traders
out there on their
cellphones all the time
tapping into a global
patent of commerce.
And one of the
things we're seeing
is that access to the
international networks
of trade, things like
remittance flows,
arbitrage, the
movement of currency
or the movement of
goods around the planet
has overtaken
agricultural surplus
as a major driver
of city growth.
So Mogadishu is
not a city that can
be sustained by the rest
of the Somali economy.
The reason that it's there
and it's that big is it's
a trading city.
It's always been
there, but now it's
not just a trading city that
sends charcoal to Yemen,
or sends cart around
the rest of the country,
and engages in basic
commodities trading.
It's also a trading city
that's international,
because you have 800,000 Somalis
in the international diaspora,
and they're connected to the 7
1/2 million Somalis that live
in the country in a way that
just never was possible before.
Another example, we
mentioned Syria earlier.
Until 2000, there was virtually
no internet, no satellite,
television, and no cell
phone access in Syria.
Hafez al-Assad, the president
of Syria from the 1970s,
came from peasant stock.
He was a bit of a Luddite.
He wasn't that interested in
allowing Syrians to connect
to the rest of the world for
a variety of obvious reasons,
and he essentially denied
access to all this connectivity
until his death in 2000.
His son, though,
Bashar al-Assad,
was a bit more of
a computer nerd.
He was the president of
the Syrian Computer Society
before becoming president.
He was a bit of a AV
club guy at college.
He was quite interested in
this issue of connectivity.
Ironically, under
their previous regime,
you could get a satellite
dish, but you did that
by getting it on
the black market
from the Syrian military who
would happily sell you one
and then track all your usage of
that satellite dish thereafter.
But after 2000, there was this
period known as the Damascus
Spring when Bashar al-Assad
through open electronic
connectivity, and we
saw this massive surge
in cell phone usage,
in internet access,
in access to
satellite television.
And actually if you
look at the other cities
and other countries
involved in the Arab Spring,
you see a very,
very similar pattern
of this explosion of
connectivity after 2000.
When the uprising came in
2011, that fundamentally
changed the way that the
conflict developed in Syria.
Unlike the 1980s
when the regime was
able to crush one city at a time
because people didn't know what
was going on, this
time people were
able to talk to each other.
And the uprising spread across
about half a dozen cities
on the first day, and
it reached 20 cities
in the first two weeks.
And so the regime was not
able to get ahead of the curve
this time.
The other critical
difference that we've
seen in all the Arab
Spring conflicts
is the way that a tech savvy
connected population that
is able to access technical
instructions but also
physical manufacturing
facilities
can rapidly generate
weaponry and capabilities
that just weren't available
even a decade ago.
And we can talk in more detail
in Q&A if you like about that.
But I'll just give
you one example.
In the Aleppo area-- which
is in northern Syria--
last year, a bunch of guys
in the Syrian free army
downloaded a bunch of
instructions off the internet
and started producing their
own mortar systems, which
they used Google Android
phones to control.
They used the compass app and
a variety of calculation tables
to decide where they're
going to fire those mortars.
They look at Google Earth
as a way of targeting,
and they'll use
access to the internet
to basically pass messages
back and forth on Twitter
to control the fall of shot.
But also they
downloaded instructions
that enabled them to build
their own army vehicles,
so in a backyard
factory in Aleppo
last year, a bunch of guys made
this thing called al-Shams,
which is their lightweight tank
that has many mono chassis.
It's about 6 feet long
and about 3 1/2 feet wide.
It's controlled with a Game
Boy console from inside,
and you look at a flat
screen television.
It doesn't have a
turret, which is actually
the most complicated piece of
an armored vehicle to build.
Instead, it has a remote
control weapon station
where they basically a
robot electric motor that
controls the 7.62
millimeter machine
gun that sits
outside the turret.
And you've got a series
of armored video cameras
that can be replaced
if they get broken that
allow the thing to basically
run through a Go Pro
to a Game Boy
controller, and the guy
drives it around the
streets of Aleppo
using basically home
consumer entertainment
technology to control it.
When I showed it to a bunch of
army guys earlier this year,
they said to me, well, why would
you take all that technology
and put it into this tiny
little army vehicle that's
only 3 feet wide and 6 feet
long and it can't fight
another tank, because it
only has a machine gun?
Well, the reason is because
tanks can't get down
streets in a place like Aleppo.
A Bradley armored fighting
vehicle is about 16 feet wide,
so is an Abrams tank.
They're not getting that.
They're not going to get
into that environment,
and it doesn't need a big gun.
It needs a small machine
gun for fighting infantry,
because it's not
going to be dealing
with large armored vehicles.
So this is actually a very
smart technical adaptation
of consumer electronics with
basically well understood
internal combustion engine
and the application of fire
in an urban environment.
But what's interesting about
this is not the technology
itself.
It's the way that all
these people concentrated
in an urban environment with
a high degree of connectivity
have actually democratized
military technology
on the ground.
And the way these
conflicts have developed
is very different from how
previous irregular warfare
conflicts developed.
I have case studies in
the book on that stuff
and on things like
the Mumbai attack
where the Lashkar-e-Taiba
terrorists from Pakistan
used Twitter as
their control feed
to actually control the attack
and used downloads of Google
Earth to understand the flow of
the city and how to attack it.
I have a bunch of
other case studies.
Probably the most
interesting to me
is actually the way that
Jamaican drug gangs in Kingston
have used urban planning
decisions made in the 1960s
to create these Garrison
districts around the outside
of the city and control
international drug
trade from slum areas around
the capital city of Jamaica.
But let me finish by
talking about I think what's
more germane to this discussion,
which is how do we model
and understand
cities under stress.
Because if I'm right
about the future,
then the future
environment is going
to be one of cities
that are experiencing
this tsunami of inflow of
population, and information,
and money, and drugs,
and weapons that
come about through
rapid urbanization.
And it's worth thinking about
how do we model and understand
those and how do we think
about resiliencies to address
those problems going forward.
So briefly on that, in
looking at this in the book,
I go back to Karl
Marx, weirdly enough.
So Marx-- whatever
else he may have been--
was a social scientist who's
looking at European cities
100 years after the beginning
of that Industrial Revolution
process that I was
talking about earlier.
So in the 1850s, Marx is
looking at Paris, and Berlin,
and London, and he's saying what
is it about these cities that
gives rise to the
environment of urban squalor
that is famously
written about by people
like Victor Hugo
and Charles Dickens.
What is it that
gives rise to that?
And he talks about what
he calls a metabolic rift.
So that people that
are used to living
in a rural environment, where
most of the people that you
rely on for day-to-day survival
are people that you're either
related to or you
know personally.
And you're in this
organic structure,
you then find yourself in
a large urban environment
where everything's
depersonalized,
and you now rely on these large
institutionalized distanciated
systems that are essentially
lots of moving parts
that all have to work together,
or the whole thing falls over.
And he talks about how that
creates this social rift
in the way that people
look at each other,
but it disassociates them
from the means of survival.
This idea sits fallow in urban
planning for about 100 years,
and then a guy called
Abel Wolman picks it up
in the 1960s, who
was an urban planner,
and he writes an
article that's actually
very seminal in
urban ecology where
he talks about the
metabolism of cities.
And Wolman's argument is
pretty straightforward.
It's like if you
imagine your body
as a system with various inputs
and intakes of water, fuel,
food, and so on that
come into your body,
and there are
transformative processes
that result in energy
and biomass and so on.
But they also result
in toxins that
have to be metabolized
and dealt with.
And if your body doesn't
have the carrying capacity,
the metabolic systems in place
to deal with those toxins,
then you're going to get sick.
He says you can apply
the same idea to a city.
It has various
inputs and inflows
and has various
transformative processes,
and if the inflows overwhelm
the carrying capacity
of the system, then you're going
to see the emergence of toxins
that are going to result in
stuff like pollution-- air
pollution, water
pollution, and so on.
Now, this idea is
very common now
in urban ecology in the
physical sense, carbon, water,
air, how these things flow
through an urban system.
And there are
models that we use,
and there are material
flow analysis systems
that we apply to
understand that.
What I've done and what
a lot of other people
have done in looking at cities
in the last 10 or 20 years
is to do what I would call a
non-material flow analysis.
So instead of looking
at water or carbon,
we'll look at information, and
money, and people, and weapons,
and drugs, and say does the
city have the carrying capacity
to deal with those flows, or is
it in fact getting overwhelmed.
And when you apply
those kinds of models
to cities under
stress, it turns out
you can start looking at
them in a very different way,
and I can give you again some
examples in Q&A from places
we've worked in Africa and
Latin America to understand
how a city can be
seen as essentially
a patent of intersecting
flows rather than just
a piece of organized terrain.
Modeling that, we
have found what
relies on a combination of
big data, remote observation
of honest signals from the urban
environment with field teams
that can understand
what's beneath that data.
So we did a lot of work
initially in Afghanistan,
and then subsequently in Syria,
and in much of other places
in looking at environments
that are under stress
and trying to understand
what was going on
by remote observation.
After a while, we realized
that that doesn't actually
give you the answer
you're looking for.
It's like looking at a
jungle canopy from above.
You can see the trees, but you
don't know what's underneath.
And it turns out that
you have to put a field
team on the ground
to figure out what
is the delta between
the observed data
and what you can
see on the ground
before you can start to make
predictive analysis about what
you're looking at.
So I'll give you one example,
and unfortunately, Google
doesn't come into this story,
because you guys charge
for use of Google Earth data.
But we used Open
Street Map, which
is the Wiki version
of Google Earth
to work with a series
of communities, mainly
women's groups and a
violence observatory
in a large African city
on a coastline that
has a number of slums
that are experiencing
a really high
degree of violence.
Now, why women?
One of the reasons
that women are
really important in
this environment--
there's actually two reasons.
One is because they
are consistently
excluded from the analysis.
So when you go and start looking
at environments on the ground,
typically you end up
speaking with elite class
urban males that
speak English, which
is a pretty small subset
of the environment
actually when you
want to understand
what's really going on.
But much more
importantly in my view
is that something
like 80% of the people
that own businesses and
employ people in slums
are actually women,
and the reason for that
is pretty obvious.
A lot of these slums
don't have a lot of jobs.
Like if you live
in la Rocinha which
is a favela outside
of Rio, you aren't
going to work in la Rocinha.
You're going to work downtown
where the rich people need you
to sweep streets, and run
the airport traffic, baggage
handling system, or drive taxis.
That's where the work is if
you're a guy in la Rocinha.
If you want to
work in the favela,
and you want to run a business,
so you want to employ people,
then you're probably
part of this network
of women small business
owners that are actually
pretty common in
these environments.
So we worked with
these women's groups
to understand threat
and risk in their slum.
And if you think
about it, when you
walk through an
urban environment,
you don't know if you're
going to be mugged,
but you do know if it
is going to happen,
it'll probably be over there.
There's just something
about the environment
that tells you that it's risky.
And we built a map which
essentially reflected
the community's
perception of risk
in different specific
areas within a slum.
And it's interesting when you
compare that to the police data
that the police have-- which
is again remote observation--
you would think
that the government
of a large African
city would know what's
going on in its environment.
Mostly they don't.
You can look at
these things, and you
can identify any building
off of Google Earth,
but if you talk to somebody
from the government,
it's pretty rare for them
to be able to tell you
what that building is.
Even if they know
what the building is,
most of these streets
don't have street names.
There are no house
addresses, so there's
no way to record
that information.
So we built these
special models of where
the community felt unsafe,
and we began looking at them.
We realized that actually these
places have a visual signature.
There's something about
them that's different,
the size of houses, the
number of bins in a given
distance of road,
how wide the streets
are, the density
of urban lighting.
There's a whole
variety of things
that make these
areas look different,
and often humans can't tell
that, but machines can.
And when you back up to a lot
of scale model or large scale
picture, just a satellite
image of a city,
you can start to pick these
environments off the map,
because you know what
you're looking for,
because you've done
the field work.
So just the big
data is not enough,
and just the field
work is not enough.
The magic happens
at the connectivity
between field teams that
understand the environment who
are almost always entirely
indigenous local inhabitants
of that environment and
people sitting remotely
who can understand the
bigger large end perspective.
And so a lot of what we do
now in places in Africa,
and Latin America,
and the Middle East
is founded on an idea
that we co-ed design
where we bring a small external
team with certain kinds
of technical or
functional knowledge
into an environment
where they work closely
under the direction of
the local community.
And I'm going to take
this back to warfare.
I really first
experienced that in Iraq
when we finally
began to turn around
what we'd been doing in Iraq.
And I'm going to
end with this story,
and then I'll throw
it open to questions.
When I first went into Iraq
in 2006, we were in free fall.
3,000 civilians were getting
killed in just Baghdad city
alone e every week.
That's a 9/11 every week.
By September of 2007,
we'd reduced that
to the point where a few people
getting killed was a bad night.
100 was a terrible week.
95% reduction in
violence in just
a seven month period in Iraq.
How did we do that?
It wasn't because we had this
great new counter insurgency
manual.
That helped.
I wasn't because we had a
president who was very engaged.
Although, we wouldn't have been
able to do it without that.
But actually it was because
we finally did something
that we never
really done before,
which is to actually start
talking to the Iraqis
about how to defend
their neighborhoods.
So before that, we
had typically gone
into an Iraqi neighborhood, and
we would swept the locals out
of the way, and we'd
say sit down, shut up.
We have the answer
to your problem.
We're going to back up
this democracy truck.
We're going to
unpack the solution,
and you guys will be very
happy with the result.
And what had happened
was not that.
What had happened was a city
that had basically torn itself
apart for those 12 to 18
months before the surge began.
And in that time,
interestingly the period
when we backed off from
Baghdad, a lot of local security
councils had emerged,
and people had
started to create these
little security groups that
decided we're
going to figure out
how to defend our own
community and they had actually
gone out and put in place
a whole series of systems,
not just physical systems,
but reporting systems,
and information
management systems,
and ways of understanding
their environment,
which they had used to
survive through most of 2006.
So when we finally went
back in the spring of 2007
and began to reengage
with Baghdad,
this time we sat
down with people,
and we said tell us what you've
been doing for the last year,
and what's worked, and
what hasn't worked,
and what you need some
additional help on,
and what we should
just not touch,
and you give us
this design brief
of what we should
build to support
your security in
your environment.
And initially they
were like, what?
Because I actually had a meeting
with some guys in a place
called Sadr City where
they were like, what?
You want to know what we think?
They were like, dude,
we've been working
with the Coalition
for four years.
You're the first person
that's ever asked us
what we think about how
to secure our district.
And they were very,
very suspicious.
When we finally began to do this
stuff-- and it wasn't just me,
it was people all over
Iraq-- they got religion.
Because they saw that
we really were serious.
We were really going to listen
to what they wanted to do,
and we're going
to work with them.
And we engaged in this
process of co-design,
and we actually
designed stuff together
to build a solution that
would work for them.
Now, there's companies here
in San Francisco like IDEO,
for example, that
have this idea down
in terms of participatory
development and urbanization,
and they understand stuff
like human centered design
as a way of engaging
with communities
that are under stress to try
to build a better solution.
My challenge to them and
what our company's been doing
has been trying to
figure out how do you
do that when people
are shooting at you.
How do you do that when it's
so violent that you can't just
sit down with people and say
hey man, what should we do?
What are the ways
you can observe
that environment
remotely, and how can you
have field teams
working the ground
to try to build-- what
for want of a better term
I would call-- peace and
resilience in environments that
are just not stable
by definition.
These cities are growing at such
a rate that our traditional way
of thinking about the problem,
which is to bring stability,
to stabilize-- as
the IMF has it ,
or to bring stability operations
as the military talks about is
just not going to work.
If you were born
in Daka in 1950,
you would have been born in
a city of 400,000 people.
Today that city's 12 million.
It's going to be 25 million
by the middle of the century.
It's not a stable system.
Stability is a systems
characteristic.
Resiliency is a characteristic
who's act is in the system.
Rather than trying to hold back
the tide of rapid urbanization,
we need to be focusing on
how to teach people to swim,
and that's a lot of
what most people that
are working in this
environment are now doing.
So US Aid and a lot of
the other aid agencies
have now a resiliency
agenda for how
they're going to bring
the kind of systems
to communities that
allow them to be
resilient in the
face of rapid change.
And I think circling back to
that Afghan ambush, that's
what we need to be
looking at going forward,
not remote rural mountainous
environments where you don't
have a lot of
connectivity, and you
don't have a high
population density.
We've become really,
really good at operating
in that environment
in the last decade,
but the future
environment is not that.
It's big cities on
coastlines in the developing
world with an enormous
degree of connectivity,
and there's a massive
upside set of opportunities
to lift people out of poverty,
to bring all kinds of benefits
to communities that
don't have them now,
to actually generate peace
as this thing from just
the absence of conflict.
That opportunity is there
alongside a huge set
of risks that will confront
us if we don't deal
with this massive population
tsunami that's bearing down
on coastal cities in
the next generation.
So let me stop
there and summarize
by saying we need to get our
heads out of the mountains,
and start thinking about this
future urban environment.
And I'm going to throw the
floor open to questions,
so I don't know how
you want to run.
If you guys want to nominate,
and we'll go from there.
AUDIENCE: When we
were speaking earlier,
you had talked about inoculating
cities with some resiliency
as they're going through
this rapid growth.
Could you talk a little
bit more about that please?
DAVID KILCULLEN: So
great point, Chris.
So, we're not just talking
about cities that are there now.
One projection by
the Indian Institute
for Human Settlements-- which is
like their heart organization--
is that the entire
west coast of India
is going to be one single
giant conurbation by 2040.
So large slums will fill in
the currently existing space
between existing cities.
There's a guy called
Mike Davis out in Hawaii
who's written a number of
really good books, one which
is called "Planet of Slums"
where he projects that we're
going to see this
giant slum spoil fill
in the space between
existing cities.
So there's paradoxes that a lot
of the problems of urbanization
that we're going to see
in the next generation
are going to happen in
cities that aren't there yet,
because they haven't
happened yet.
And so part of this is about
getting ahead of the curve
and thinking about what do
these kinds of environments
need to channel them into a
pathway of urban development
that's going to result
in a different future.
And I'm trying in the book not
to predict a dystopian view.
If you want that,
go read "Snow Crash"
by Neal Stephenson,
which is 15 years old,
but it's all there
in California.
So this stuff's been figured out
as a dystopian vision already.
What I'm doing is
making a projection
based on current
data and saying it
doesn't have to be that future.
It can actually be different.
And I think it's about thinking
about where will cities grow to
and what happens when rapid
unchecked urban growth acretes
around an existing city.
So you get this donut shaped
or horseshoe shaped ring
of terrain that clusters
around an existing city,
but it didn't used
to be empty terrain.
That's where the
city grew its food.
It's where the water
catchment area was.
It's where a lot of the
transportation roots
come through.
So you have this
ring of slums that
emerge around a
city that separates
the city from the sources of
all those critical commodities,
the inflows of the metabolism
that it needs to survive.
And these are areas
where you don't
have a lot of
government presence.
You don't have a lot
of government services.
And so non-state
armed groups often
emerge and end up controlling
these environments,
and they don't
just smuggle drugs.
They actually provide governance
services in these environments.
And it's typical of governments
to look at these as a threat.
I don't see them
that way at all.
These are people who
are engaging in stuff
that the government
either can't or won't
do that the population needs.
They're actually fulfilling
a central function
to the existence of
the city, but what
it means if you're an
urban politician downtown
is there's now a ring
of territory that's
like a gauntlet around the
city, and all the supplies
that the city needs
to survive have
to run that gauntlet
every day, and there's
a non-state armed group, a
malitia, or a communitarian
group that's sitting
astride that.
And you're going to have
to deal with that group,
because if you don't, they
can shut the city down.
So I think it's stuff like that.
It's understanding how
do we enable urban growth
in a way that isn't
going to generate
the kind of urban exclusion,
and marginalization,
and political disposition
of these people
that then creates the ground
in which all this stuff takes
place.
And for the military
guys, how are we
going to operate in giant
cities like this which
could absorb a marine regiment
or an army division and not
even notice?
It's going to have to be
different from the traditional
way that we've thought
about operational maneuver
from the sea or
maneuver operational
in a littoral environment,
because it's just so big now
that you're looking at
a whole different space.
A lot more to talk
about on that,
but I think getting
ahead of the curve
is about predicting where
the problem is going
to be in cities that
haven't even happened yet
and how do you understand
the resiliences that prevent
this kind of symptoms
from developing
and to stop them
in their tracks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Let's see.
Max Boot spoke here recently.
He's the author of the
book on guerrilla warfare.
And at one point
he said-- I think
I'm quoting him right--
that urban areas were not
very friendly for
guerrillas, and his reason
was that it's too exposed.
You can't have
meetings and organize.
You can't do rifle practice.
Clearly you disagree.
Do you think that's a
factor, or [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KILCULLEN: Well,
I think Max was just
a great book in his
latest book, and I
have a lot of respect
for his point of view.
And I think if you look at
the big sweep of history
of guerrillas, which is
what he's doing in the book,
he's right that traditionally
guerrillas don't operate
in cities and haven't had
a great degree of success
in cities.
And the reason for
that is guerrillas
go to where the cover is.
They go to where they can hide.
And for most of
human history, that's
been mountains and
jungles, but today we
have foliage penetrating radar
that can see through jungles.
And we've got drones that can
sit on top of a mountain range
24 hours a day and tell
you where the bad guys are.
There's not a lot of cover in
the rural environment anymore.
The cover is in the cities.
And there's another
key idea that
comes in here, which is
the idea of legibility.
So there's a great
guy up at Yale
called James C. Scott
who's a professor.
I don't think you can be
a professor of [INAUDIBLE]
studies, but that's
basically what he is.
And he wrote an
awesome book called
"Seeing Like a State"
where he talks about how
what governments
try to do is they
try to make
environments legible,
so they can read and interpret.
And if you work in
Google, you basically work
in a giant legibility
project, trying
to make the entire planet
legible so the people can
understand that and
do things with it.
There are huge parts of the
planet that are not legible,
and most of those places
now are in cities.
They're not in well developed
well designed cities.
They're in these
clusters of slums
where there's no
street addresses,
and there's no house numbers,
and you can spot a building
from space, but you
don't know what's there,
and there's no way to
understand who lives there.
Now that we have things like
GDELT-- the global database
of events, language,
and tone-- which
has been built for
about 15 years or so,
and we have Twitter feeds
that we can geolocate.
There's things that are emerging
that allow us to make cities
more legible than
they'd been in the past.
But I believe the
balance has shifted
so that the urban
environment is now
the safer environment for
irregular operators compared
to the countryside.
That doesn't mean we won't
see conflict in the mountains
and in the jungles.
We most definitely will.
But irregular conflict tends
to happen where people live.
The vast majority
of people are going
to be in urban environments,
and the city now
is the area where
you've got more
cover than the
rural environment.
So I think Max is right as a
historical statement about what
the history of irregular
conflict has been,
but I think we're at a watershed
where going forward we're
going to see increasing
preponderance of this kind
of conflict happening
not in downtown cities,
but in slums and in this ring
of uncontrolled illegible
territory around the outside.
AUDIENCE: So you
talk about where
you think the slums are going
to grow and try to get ahead
of it, but it seems like any
service you do in that area
before the slums is
just going to draw
the people there and
bring the slum sooner.
If you put schools
and parks, you're
just going to end up with
slums at the schools and parks.
How do you get ahead of it?
The real problem is
just too much people
with not enough jobs.
DAVID KILCULLEN: Right,
that's a great point.
In fact, there's a woman
called Sheela Patel who
runs an organization
called SPARC in Mumbai who
makes this point.
She says the government has
decided not to provide services
to people in slums,
because they think
it's going to attract
people to the slums.
One of the great examples
of that is sanitation.
So the Indian government
says that an acceptable level
of sanitation is one
toilet per 50 people.
Right now it's one
toilet per 600 people
in many of the slums in Mumbai.
And she says as if
people moved to slums
just because they want
access to a toilet.
There's plenty of places
to crap in the woods.
Actually people are
moving to cities
because of economic opportunity.
And I also think--
and we see this
in a number of places--
because of the connectivity
differential between
rural environments
and the urban
environment, if now
the way that you make
your money is by access
to a globalized economy
and you need connectivity
to do that and there's a
connectivity differential
between the rural environment
where you don't have
that connectivity and the
urban environment when you do,
then one of the major reasons
why people are moving to cities
is because that's
where the Wi-Fi is.
That's where the internet is.
That's where the density
of cell phone coverage
is that allows you to tap
into that environment.
So I think that
tells you that there
are three ways to
really address this.
One is to attack
the supply side,
to do things in the
rural environment that
make it better for people that
are there so that they don't
decide we're going to pick up
and move to urban environments
at quite the same rate.
So more rural Wi-Fi, better
access to cell phones
in the countryside, water,
sanitation, education, conflict
resolution in the
kinds of conflicts
we were talking about
here that will still
happen in the rural
environment, there's
a supply side problem
of how do you address
people deciding to
move to the city.
Then in the city itself,
there are all these resiliency
interventions that you
can undertake in order
to make it hard of a
conflict to break out,
to create ways to resolve
that conflict quicker,
and to bring in the kinds of
services that prevent conflicts
from developing in
the first place.
So they're the demand
side, or how do you
increase the carrying capacity
of an urban system in such
a way that it can
handle the flow?
But then ultimately, though,
AUDIENCE: I think
nothing we can do
is going to stop the giant
tendency of populations
to move to urban environments.
It's more about helping
people cope better
with the environment
they find themselves
in than about
turning off the tap.
AUDIENCE: I just have trouble
seeing how to grow resiliency
when it means a slum is stronger
because more people live there.
I mean, that's resiliency
in the anti-fragile sense.
You get stronger because
more people come.
I don't see how to do that.
DAVID KILCULLEN:
There's actually-- well,
you should buy my book
then, because there's
a lot of case studies in there.
In the last chapter, I look
at several examples of things
that I think suggest
ways to think about this.
I would just say
I'm not suggesting
that I have the answer.
What I'm doing is
pointing to two things.
One is there's this
problem out there which
we need to be
thinking about, and I
think that actually
in the urban studies
environment and actually a lot
of people in the data science
community, people are
already thinking about that.
But the military's
been sidetracked
into this other environment
for the last decade,
and as we come back out
of that environment,
I think we have to put that
conversation back together
again and have people that
really understand military,
and law enforcement,
and all those kinds
of other kinds of operations
in the environment,
reengage with a
debate that's actually
moved on a lot in
the last 12 years
while we've been
busy in Afghanistan.
And the other thing that I
think it is to reemphasize
is you have littoral,
because being on a coastline
is different from being
in a city elsewhere.
Just one example
of that, last year
for the first time
in history, there
was a simultaneous outbreak of
cholera in four West African
countries during
the monsoon season,
and the reason
for that is people
have moved to slums on the
outskirts of these cities.
A lot of those slums are
built on stilts over the sea.
They don't have sanitation.
There was a tidal storm surge
that pushed a lot of sewage
from these slums into the inland
water system and infected lots
of people with cholera,
but all these cities
are connected with each other
through coastal shipping
and air transportation so that
the infection spread nearly
simultaneously.
There's a very interesting
study by the World Health
Organization where they look
at how air travel in particular
completely invalidates our
traditional way of handling
infectious disease.
If you have the right
incubation period
and you posit the idea of a
continued air traffic system,
it can be around
the entire system
before the first
patient gets sick.
So instead of having breakout
in one country and you then
contain that, you can
have simultaneous outbreak
in basically every continent
except Antarctica because
of the way the air
transportation system works.
Who runs baggage handling
systems in most of the world?
Who is the workforce
in most airports?
It's people that don't live in
the rich districts downtown.
It's people that live in the
slums around the outside.
So I think this is the
sort of stuff where
we need to be really engaging to
think about how do we get ahead
of the curve, and maybe we can.
Maybe you're right.
I hope that's not true,
but it's at least worth
thinking about it I think.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
thanks for coming.
I wanted to ask about if we
have this large population
growth over the next 30 years,
have all these people moving
into cities and
then simultaneously
from other people, particularly
like futurists like Peter
Diamandis and such who have
these ideas that talk about
well, we'll have more
and more technology.
We'll have to stop worrying
about low level agriculture
so much as more of that's--
we'll just say-- automated.
So I was wondering if you had
any thoughts on what the job
or what the working situation
looks like for people
in these cities as we get
these giant populations.
DAVID KILCULLEN:
Yeah, I've looked
at that in a little
bit of detail,
but not actually as
much as I would like to.
I think there's a whole
additional study here
that's not only
focused on employment,
but it's focus on the
intersection of various things
that the aid and development
community takes for granted.
So, I had an interesting
discussing with the Gates
Foundation last year about
maternal health and infant
mortality.
And of course, if you're
running a private philanthropic
organization, you have to
define what your field of action
is going to be, and if that's
your field of action, that's
where you're going to focus.
But the fact is if you come up
with effective maternal health
and infant mortality
programs now,
you better have an education
plan for five or six
years from now, and you
better have an employment
plan for 18 years
from now, or you're
going end up with what
happened to the Libyans
where the Libyans did a great
job in the '70s and '80s
improving public health,
which resulted in a youth
bulge, which resulted in a lot
of people hitting college age.
And the Libyan education
system was well
developed for making
people literate,
giving them skills in English,
and helping them become very
politically aware, but it was
really bad at generating people
that had skills that were
relevant to the Libyan economy,
which is basically oil and gas.
So you had this massive number
of expats doing those jobs,
and a lot of people coming
out of Libyan colleges
ended up working for
the civil service,
because basically
they just created
this giant public
service in order
to absorb all these people
that didn't have usable skills.
Then you had these government
departments that were basically
just jobs programs
and didn't exist
to provide any service
to the community,
so you had this breakdown of
trust between the government
and the population and
this giant underemployment
challenge.
And that was the
recruiting pool from which
people sprung in 2011 against
the regime when they began
seeing places like
Dubai and Kuwait
on the television, which they'd
never had access to until 2003.
And they're like,
hang on a second,
how come those guys
are living like that,
and we're living like this?
So I think that issue
is critically important,
figuring out the intersections
of all these different programs
and how they work together.
I think-- and this
is just my point
of view based on not
a huge amount of data,
but just based on observing
a lot of these cities--
there's a lot of
jobs out there that
are emerging through
self-synchronization
at the local level.
So if you want to go on
your Google mapping app,
and you live in Lagos, and
you want to check the traffic,
it's useless, because
it's red all the time.
Lagos seems to have
words for traffic
like Eskimos have
words for snow.
There's so many people there.
It's the infrastructure
of a medium
sized town with a population
the size of Australia basically.
And it's always red.
But, there are about 25
different local level radio
stations that only
broadcast for a few blocks
where people call in
and tell the radio
DJ what's going on
with traffic, and you
don't go on Google
to find out traffic.
You just change--
people have written up
on their window the frequencies
of these local radio stations,
and they just change from one
to another as they move through.
And they've basically
self-synchronized
their own traffic
information system
based on totally analog
means in that environment.
So there's a lot of
those kinds of things.
And there's also
a cognitive elite,
which is not the machine.
It's the marriage
of machine and human
that's actually
driving forward a lot
of the economic development
in places that we see.
I can talk about that
offline if you want,
because it's a whole
other discussion.
But then there's a lot of people
that are basically dispossessed
because of this change, and
what happens to those people
will drive a lot of what happens
in these environments I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks for coming.
Let's have a warm hand
for David Kilcullen.
DAVID KILCULLEN: Hey,
thank you for having me.